as the saying goes be kind for everyone
you meet is fighting a battle you know
nothing about yeah it's true what's
something difficult you're going through
that people don't often see trying to
feed no I mean you
know
uh I mean my mind is a storm and I I
don't think I don't think most people
would want to be me they may think they
would want to be me but they don't they
don't know they don't
understand
um how are you
doing I mean overall
okay the grand scheme of things I can't
to
complain do you get
lonely sometimes but
I you know my kids and friends keep me
company so not
existential but there are many nights I
sleep
alone I don't have to but I
do Walter isacson in his new biography
of you wrote about your difficult
childhood will you ever find forgiveness
in your heart for everything that has
happened happened to you in that period
of your
life what is forgiveness I do
not at least I don't think I have a
resentment
um
so nothing to
forgive you know forgiveness is
difficult for
people it seems like you don't Harbor
the
resentment I mean I try to think about
like what what what is going to affect
the future in a good way um and holding
on to grudges MH does
not affect the future in a good way your
father a proud father what have you
learned about life from your
kids those little biological
organisms I mean developing AI and
watching say a little X
grow is uh fascinating um because
they they are form more parallels than I
would have
expected I mean I can see his biological
neural
net making more and more sense of the
world and I can see the digital neural
world at the same
time do you see the beauty and magic in
both
yes
I mean one of the things with with kids
is that uh you know you you kind of see
the world a new in their
eyes um you know to them everything is
new and fresh and um and then when you
when you see that them experienced them
the world is new and
fresh you do
too well Elon I just want to say thank
you for for your uh kindness to me and
friendship over the years for seeing
something in a silly kid like me as
you've done for many others and um thank
you for having hope for a positive
future for Humanity and for working your
ass off to make it happen thank you on
thanks
Lex